المعركه معركه مدفعيه بامتياز خلال الايام
الماضيه ما تغير اليوم هو بدايه حرب
الشوارع تحديدا نتحدث عن الاحياء الشرقيه
في مدينه بخمود نعلم ان هذه المدينه
يقطعها نهر بخمودكا ويقسمها الى جزئين
الجزء الشرقي خلال الاسبوع الماضي كان قد
شهد على عمليه عسكريه استطاعت فيها القوات
الروسيه التقدم قليلا داخل المدينه اليوم
كانت هناك عمليه مرتده اوكرانيه اذا هناك
عمليات عمليات كر وفر بمعنى ان الجانب
الروسي يتقدم وبعضها يعود الجانب
الاوكراني ليقوم بعمليه المضاده ليبعد
الجنود الروس من الجزء الشرقي كنا في مكان
قريبا جدا همم
اشتباكاته هناك استخدام المدفعيه هناك
استخدام كبير
واعاده الماء يتم اطلاقها وت كتير اا هذا
المكان لان الكلبه طيا يعلم انه عندما
تكون السماء صافيه هناك حركات مسيرات
كبيره من الجانبين وبالتالي من السهوله
جدا الكشف عنها هذه نكته اضافه ذاتيه
البارزه الى الله علاقه بالتعزيزات
والتحصينات التي تشمل كل احياء بخموت
تحديدا في الوسط هو غير الوسط هناك اولا
وضع لمكعبات استمتيها كبيره والاهم رايناه
اليوم هو حضر هذه
الخنادق التي يحتمي فيها الجنود في ظل
استمرار سقوط قذائف
مدفعيه همم
كان قد تاكد انسحاب الكتيبه القويه
المعروفه في اوكرانيا وهي الكتيبه التي
تحمل رقم 93 والتي لها اسم هنا لانها خاضت
معارك استطاعت فيها ان ان تنتصر على
الجانب الروسي تم سحبها في بخموت ان تدقي
لان هذه الخساره ما يتضح الان هو غير ذلك
يتطضح تغيير في هذه الكاتبه بمعنى سحب هذه
الكتيبه كي تستريح وهذا ما تاكد اليوم
التقينا بعناصر الجدد من عمليا فرق اخرى
في الجيش الاوكراني مثلا الفرقه السابعه
عشره وغيرها هؤلاء الجنود قالوا لنا انهم
او وصلوا انهم مستعدون انهم مرتاحوا في
الجبهات الخلفيه والان اتى الى بخموته
يقولون لنا انهم مستعدون لفعل كل ما يلزم
لعدم التخلي عن اي شبر ويعتبرون انه هناك
ضروري كبيره للابقاء على هذه المدينه في
ظل همم دفع القوات همم الروسيه وتحديدا
اكد دول انا وجوده قوه تحديدا في الاحياء
الشرقيه
يعني كيف تم اجلاء المدنيين كيف يتعاطى
منقى مع في المدينه مع كل اتطورات
العسكريه لهذه الخطوات التي يعني تحدث
خلفك
هذه في مدينه بخموت لا يمكن المرء ان
يتوقف عن عند هذه الاصوات صوت المدفعيه لا
يكل ولا يمهل هذا ينطبق على ما رايناه
اليوم والناس يعيشون حياتهم على وقع هذه
الاصوات على الاقل ان تحدث عن من بقي منه
ثنائي الذي رفقناه تاكدنا انه وصل مثلا
الى مدينه
نيبرو هناك فصل جديد من الحياه يبدا لكن
من بقي اليوم مثلا التقينا بهذه السيده
التي قالت لنا انها قلقه للغير موجود
انتشار التعزيزات والتحصينات داخل المدينه
بالنسبه اليها هذا ينبا لمعركه داخل
الاحياء التي كانت تطولها فقط المدفعيه
وليس حرب الشوارع هذه نقطه نقطه ثانيه
يقولون ان حالتهم الصحيه لا تسمح به
الخروج وانهم اصلا لا مكان لهم ليذهب
اليها غير مدينه محمود من المشاهد اللافته
في غرب المدينه بعيدا قليلا مركز المدينه
الذي تحتدم فيها على الاقل تعالوا فيها
اصوات المدفعيه هي هذه السوق المفتوحه
نتحدث عن طريق واسعه يلجا الناس الى الوضع
الاغراض على طاوله ياتي من يريد ان يشتري
بعض الحاجيات فيها لكن بالمحصله من بقي في
مخموط وعدد قديم قليل من الناس اما لانه
لم يستطع الخروج وامهم جدا لان له موقف
اديولوجي وهو موالا لروسيا ولو ان الكلام
لا يقال هكذا على نيه بل يتم التعبير عنه
بنوع من العدائيه عند السؤال مثلا عن ما
يجري الان في المدينه عبر القاء اللوم على
التحصينات التي يقوم بها الجيش الاوكراني
لتبريد التي تصل الى داخل البلده شكرا
جزيلا لك ميس عواد مفاجاه
الى همم
الى دروش كيف كانت تحديدا شكرا جزيلا لك